yeah I mean it'd be kind of hard for the
backup QB and training camp to be very
vocal last year so this year is
definitely a lot different
that's Baker Mayfield making it known
that he is going to exert himself in the
way that we expected he will that I
remember when they were scouting Baker
Mayfield and the little things that were
noticed at the pro day workout how his
teammates responded to him he'd make
this little sound and they'd all come
running like he was the Pied Piper and
and and that's one of the reasons why
people believe he's gonna be so special
he knows how to lead you either have it
naturally like a Peyton Manning or a Tom
Brady or your team helps prop up the
quarterback is a leader with Baker
Mayfield there's no need to prop him up
he's going to be a natural leader
wherever he plays however long he plays
if he's with the Browns his whole career
if he bounces around I know Browns fans
get nervous just the mere thought of him
not being in orange helmet his entire
career but my point is this guy is a
natural leader and it's gonna transfer
to wherever he is and whatever he does a
natural leader such a good leader that
when he was coming out in the draft I
mean people I was talking to around the
NFL we're saying the off the field stuff
with Baker Mayfield the best I've ever
seen with any player and the history of
you know their jobs or anything like
that to where people were it was so good
the off the field stuff and he was so
loved as a leader and a person and a
personality and all that that people
were like man I don't believe it I'm
gonna go back and double-check with some
people in Oklahoma because it's it's
just almost too good to be true so that
just tells you I'll let alone now it's
year two I think the most interesting
thing he said there you know it's hard
to be vocal when you're the backup
quarterback and that's so true you know
there he was last year yeah at first
pick of the draft but still he was
sitting behind Tyrod Taylor and you want
to be respectful of the guy who's in
front of you it's his team at that point
he's the main guy on the offense so he
has to be the voice that talks to the
team and the offensive line and all that
but you know once he got his chance to
play you know I saw in Pro Football Talk
yesterday some of the crap he was
talking to the Jets but you know I don't
even know who you are and things like
that you know he gets to open his mouth
show his personality and he
endeared himself to his teammates and
now you can tell they love him yeah and
and I it's one of the reasons to be very
excited about this Brown's team and it's
a tough balance because on one hand the
expectations are too high on the other
hand you start looking at what Mayfield
did last year what he has with him the
arrival of Odell Beckham jr. the
emergence of Nick Chubb the apparent
decision to focus on Chubb until Kareem
hunt returns from suspension assuming he
checks every box and does everything he
needs to do and can still play like he
did a couple of years ago the defense
getting better and better with Miles
Garrett coming into his own
Denzel Ward was great last year in his
first season there's a lot of reason to
be optimistic and the thing is you know
and and look at all the close games when
the Browns were bad and and Hugh Jackson
actually uses this as a selling point -
what a great job he did as a coach that
even when they were horrible from from a
win-loss record standpoint he still kept
games close I look at it and say look a
good coach can make the difference in a
close game and get you more wins than
one in 2016 and 0 and 2017 but I think a
quarterback who's a natural leader can
have that same impact yes did so many of
these games going to be close that if
you have a quarterback who can get out
there in the huddle with the you know
the ball in his hand the offense going
down the field with a field goal to tie
a touchdown to win with two minutes left
what he can do to elevate the rest of
his teammates that's the thing that can
make a difference between winning and
losing a game and that's why this debate
rages and we talked about it earlier
Chris quarterback wins is it a stat is
it not a stat do we put too much in it
do we not I just know this a great
leader can elevate the guys around him
and make the difference between a win
and a loss in certain circumstances
that's it I mean you know again you know
I don't care how great you are if you're
on the Arizona Cardinals and you got
apply the New England Patriots man it's
gonna be tough sledding you know your
leadership can be through the roof and
all that and I don't give a damn you're
gonna have a hard time won in that game
but we're great book quarterbacks really
come into play to like play off of what
you're saying Mike and your point is get
those games where it's even men
and both teams are playing good football
and gosh it's been closed all day long
who has the edge and the great
quarterbacks what they can do is keep
their keen calm in late in games and
lead that way and still execute and keep
everybody on the same page and all those
crucial situations so that everybody
does execute the proper way and then the
great quarterback can make a play that
maybe some of the average quarterbacks
in football can't make in some of those
situations - to where that gives their
team the advantage in a very close
football game and they come out winning
because of maybe two or three plays at
that great quarterback you're talking
about made to win the game for them yeah
and I agree with everything you have
said and that is why that debate is
never going away whether or not a win
counts as a statistical eye quarterback
well cuz I really believe that their
insight again I'm not gonna use it as a
blanket observation right but I really
do believe Baker Mayfield is gonna be
the difference this year in four or five
games and I think he was the defense the
difference last year in three or four
games for the Browns yeah no I mean yes
definitely you know I mean there's no
doubt about it it's still a team sport I
mean this is a good conversation about
wins and quarterbacks and all that
because I could show you other
quarterbacks they've won a lot of games
and I go well the defense the run game
that's why they won games but you know
again it's it's a good one and we'll get
into it later
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports